you're from what from what you've said
not insulting you're from a very small
town with not a lot to offer yes and it
sounds to me like you did a whole lot as
much as I could with the resources that
would give it right I mean on why
shouldn't we expect that from everyone
else
so nothing are you saying that you don't
think you deserve a spot at UT are you
saying that you think you got in because
you're black time for the latest
installment of changed my mind where we
rationalized our positions on
controversial topics for this
installment we return to UT Austin to
tackle the subject of affirmative action
this is Fisher versus the University of
Texas question of whether race can be
used as an admissions criteria to u.s.
colleges and universities if the nation
has done something special against the
Negro as we were then called for 240
years the nation must do now something
special for the negro so merit is
dependent upon who counts what is
meritoriously actually had so many great
conversations that will be releasing
several installments less this video be
three hours long so stay tuned for more
including one with a UT professor of
hip-hop now of course there are always
those aren't as excited to see us
y'all erases steven crowder y'all I
would probably punch him if I saw as
always if you want these videos to
continue please do consider joining mug
club at $69 annually for students
veterans active military you get this
wonderful hand etched mug the full daily
show not available on YouTube along with
the entire blaze TV's catalog at louder
with credit comm slash mug club if not
at least bookmark this channel and check
back for new videos every weekday at
9:00 p.m. Eastern before we get started
with our conversation with Tina here I
want you to know that this is one of the
most intensely personal change my mind
conversations in recent memory before we
get to that let me know what you think
about affirmative action is it racist by
its very definition is it not should
race be a determining factor in college
admissions at all let me know in the
comments below but here we go on with a
very revealing conversation with Tina
her name is Tina yes my name is Steven
nice to meet you Tina I appreciate you
taking the time to sit down I don't know
how familiar you are at all with kind of
what we do here what this program is but
the basic idea is providing an
opportunity to hopefully not be
interrupted by clock towers
there we go now I did the whole song
okay
[Music]
it's a charming quality it is charming
ish it's a little bit annoying kind of
like being in Hamtramck now and you hear
the the Islamic call to prayer five
times a day you're like what's going on
oh I'm just concerning get used to it
you get used to it after a while yeah I
don't know that the Polish do who are
living there for a long time
so let me kind of explain this change my
mind is the opportunity to sit down and
have hopefully a productive conversation
where we rationalize our positions
typically using the Socratic method on
what are seen as controversial topics
today's topic was actually requested by
students of UT because of a history here
and it being a hot topic it is my
position that affirmative action
specifically as it relates to campus
applications and acceptance is racist by
definition I don't agree with it you are
more than welcome to change my mind if
you think I'm wrong well to begin I can
I tell my story I mean I just want a lot
of data because I wasn't prepared coming
here no that's fine I grew up in a bit
like in a very poor rural area um
Longview East Texas
we'd have a lot of opportunities I have
a relative in law from Longview actually
Longview would go to
Tyler right is that where they have the
big escalator yeah yeah okay um
basically I don't want it until Tatom at
all
no it's a wonderful school but like
we've kind of on the like career tracks
and the big tracks at least I know we're
like welding
oh you'll feel training and then like we
did a nursing school nearby Soviet
trades straight yeah
and so I need to hook this whole nursing
trade okay we didn't have a lot of
resources but I'm glad I went to Tatum
it's a great school but again we didn't
have a lot of resource we didn't have a
P we didn't have IB we just had honors
and I did very well however it was
because of the low resources I feel like
I wouldn't have gotten in or had if I
for compared to like awesome school
students okay high school because they
have AP that IB there's resources to do
well in college and it wasn't for
affirmative action students like me I
feel like would have less of a chance to
go to a place like Tatum or that all
these majors and different organizations
that would have helped students like be
more capable to get a job sure well I
guess a couple of questions can I ask
you first off not knowing your personal
story but I am very interested how do
you believe that affirmative action
helped you specifically it would have
given me um I guess I'm a holistic look
like due to my like I don't have any ap
IB I didn't have much organizations I
went to sure so I was quite sparse when
it comes to that sort of resume right I
had a huge like a great essay coming
from an immigrant family
yeah that's first-generation American
okay because they're able to say okay
she she's not only black but she came
from immigrant family and because she
went through all these adversities
mm-hmm
she's still qualified to go to UT it's
not just based on your resume academic
or service resume okay but it sounds
like you so that you did perform well
like your schools yes I did I did and
that's no joke yeah um it was just that
anyone can like really do well
academically like you know I feel like
no no not anyone can do well
academically that's an accomplishment
and I think that's an important that's a
far more important measurement of who
you are than your race because it's a
performative measurement you chose to
work hard and be good in school
you chose a career path you chose to
write a formidable essay I think that's
a great thing I just don't see how your
race entering into the equation
if these performative standards were met
which it sounds like they were would
help you would that be like what
confirmed like I Tatum small school
small resource forgive me I'm not for
super familiar with Tatum is Tatum I did
him to the high club
Oh Tatum is a high school you went and
you're saying there were no high schools
in your area that had AP Sciences and
you're studying AP here what are you
studying now
I'm studying political communication and
I'm going into marketing okay so I'm
confused
how would you need those classes well
like to get into the place like UT
mmm-hmm I'd have a lot and like I was
the top of my class but only in that
small pool of like I'd have much
competition sure but like if I go to a
place like long long do high school
right is that bigger yes a lot bigger
forgive me I'm not super familiar I see
them both as relatively small towns I I
feel like I wouldn't have done as well
okay because they had more resources and
oh that stuff I don't understand that
they did you did hold on a second let me
let me cuz you seem like a very bright
person you did really well in a school
with few resources and you believe that
if you had taken your work ethic right
in your level of intelligence which
performed very well with very sparse
resources you believe that if someone
cried are you more resources you would
perform more poorly I would imagine the
opposite wouldn't be like with a bigger
pool of students more competition more
brighter students well sure there's more
competition but you would have far more
resources
it's just I feel like people who didn't
have those resources race if they look
at the race and be like okay um you had
these different adversities you uh it's
still important
we still need these type of people
because if it wasn't it goes based just
based on like a blank academic like
resume or like a blank what's not based
on a blank academic resume it is based
on a you know observable concrete
metrics so for example your SAT scores
or your a CT scores your overall grades
your extracurriculars right all of these
things are performative what is not
performative is being born black and I
don't believe that that should enter the
equation because I think first off can I
can I say and I don't want you to take
this the wrong way it sounds to me like
you respectfully are struggling with a
little self-doubt we were saying that
maybe if not for affirmative action you
may not have made it to this school and
that's sad to me because I believe that
if we take someone with fewer resources
like yourself who made her resume sing
and dance and was a brilliant student
and we gave you more resources I believe
you were brilliant with little and I
believe that you would be brilliant with
more I think for you to think of
yourself that only because of a
government program you got into this
great school it's kind of sad as opposed
to relating it to your accomplishments
forgive me that's how that's how I view
it do you understand what I mean I do
it's because I see someone who did who
came out of adversity who came from a
school that didn't have a lot to offer
and did well regardless seems to me that
actually affirmative action which would
view you through the prism of race
rather than your accomplishments would
be self-defeating I guess if you put it
that way it would be but maybe I'm very
independent like I'm independent voter
but like mm-hmm
and that well as well-versed at
composites as I should be sure but
how would you promote more a new pub
yeah
how would you promote more minority out
you know cuz usually when I view
Republicans have you look at Bill
O'Reilly well I hope you don't view me
as Bill O'Reilly and might see my hands
are above the table there's no there's
no groping going on here well first off
I don't want to Sarah Lee talked about
Republican outreach because we are
talking about affirmative action I do
agree with you that there has been
horrible messaging from Republicans it
is interesting to me that oh I think
it's thirty four percent of black
Americans approve of the job that Donald
Trump is doing which is a huge chain
from in the past so I do believe that
there have been some inroads made just
because people are able to think more
independently now and I think a big
reason for that is for the longest time
people were told I would imagine this is
true correct me if I'm wrong you were
probably taught that as a black person
vote Democrat right and I think that's
changing a little bit now particularly
in the post kind of Obama era where he
didn't really do necessarily a whole lot
for black Americans where people are
looking at it a little more critically
so I have my own thoughts on that I
don't necessarily want to get to the
Republican outreach but maybe we can
talk about it later but but back to the
idea of affirmative action now let me
ask you this you said you come from
you're first generation immigrant family
so could you tell me a little bit about
your family and your parents my parents
I came from yeah so they immigrated here
to the US I know that the traditional
it's a great immigrant story had they
rose to the top but like my parents
due to their low acting like they they
weren't able to pursue a lot
academically mm-hm
which is why they didn't get like a you
know suddenly rose to the top sort of
story I'm sure they they mostly stayed
as a gas station okay yes they owned a
gas station both burns together yes okay
I'm have they done pretty well for
themselves pretty stable middle class at
least rural area okay but then it
allowed you to pursue what you wanted to
yes your parents still together
Du Bois that's okay really divorce when
you were young or more recently
more recently so you grew up with your
parents in the house oh okay well this
is why that's important because you
talked about this
I don't see I don't see this is
necessarily a black versus white thing
but the biggest the biggest factor that
indicates socioeconomic status whether
it's going to college whether it's
performing well academically
whether it's ending up in prison whether
it's depression whether having a family
of your own is having a dual parent
household as a matter of fact the
chances of you being born into poverty
if you have two parents and they waited
until they were married to have children
there's a 98% chance that you don't end
up in poverty and a 70% chance that you
guys end up at least in the middle-class
and then there's a bunch of other
percentages I can give you where they
end up actually being the top 20% 70% of
Americans but the biggest indicator is
not college degree it's not race you see
this across all races it's whether you
have two parents in the household now
this is important because if you go back
to the 1960s black Americans had and a
lot of them also were immigrants
actually of a lot of Ethiopian friends I
went to Ethiopian church in Los Angeles
for a little while and very welcoming
people very welcoming and food was a big
thing I mean we'd sit and we I learned
the squishy bread all that yes I didn't
like it at first the texture was a
little weird right but by itself it's
kind of spongy yeah so wonderful family
by the way but very all of them this
girl's uncle's her sister they all had
pretty strong marriages I don't know if
that's a cultural thing with Ethiopia
seems like a very family post so from
the 1960s black Americans had a
single-parent household Rader follow his
household rate of under 25% that has
since gone to almost 80% of black
Americans today either don't have a mom
or a dad typically don't have a father
and that is the biggest indicator of
someone ending up in poverty rather than
a college degree so I think that's
important to note because affirmative
action has been focusing on the wrong
problem assuming that if we view through
the prism of race applicants and simply
get more black students into colleges
regardless of qualifications that they
will perform better that it will
equalize the economic disparity and it
sounds to me like here what you're
talking about is not so much a racial
disparity but an economic one
rural area so it sounds almost like
you're making the case against
affirmative action as it stands based on
race but the idea of providing resources
to those of lower socioeconomic status
am I correct in that yes but wouldn't
that isn't those sound racist it's just
you and I isn't those of low
socioeconomic status usually minorities
often yeah and that's why I'm saying a
big part of that is because of a 77%
single household rate with black
Americans Asian Americans actually make
more than white Americans on average and
they actually are harmed by affirmative
action I don't know if you're aware of
this but with the Harvard lawsuit yes
yeah they're very racist against Asians
and the personality and the reason for
that is because they tend to score
higher so for example in Harvard with
these documents that were released on
average an asian-american applicant
would have to score 1,300 on the SATs a
white American student sorry 1350 a
white American student would have to
score 1310 on average a black American
student we have to score 1100 does that
seem right to you because many of those
asian-americans also come from families
where their gas station owners or bodega
owners were simple to the seem fair to
you to exclude people based exclusively
on race rather than academic performance
especially as someone who's performed so
well academically right it's just I
don't know do you work hard
oh yes sir I guess and you wanted to go
to UT yes sir I did that makes me happy
that's what I want to see and I don't
want to see it because you go you
because you're black yeah I want you to
know that's because you worked hard and
to me that's a racism of soft
expectations you know imagine if you're
a black student who didn't score so well
right had a lower SAT score didn't score
so well and you know that you're in the
university as a diversity applicant
that's self-doubt and that's one thing I
don't want you to have it it to me seems
so sad to have for the rest of your life
to go man did I really deserve the spot
or was it because of the color of my
skin and I think that's why we see
detrimental effects you know black
Americans because of
come on don't move there's a spider on
your shoulder I don't know if you're
fighters I hate spiders I hate spiders
it was right there okay I start my
heart's going like this say I do not
like spiders we see a much higher
dropout rate was black Americans at
university or them making up a
disproportionately high percentage of
the lower performing students in the
class because they've been accepted with
lower academic performance and then they
tend to do poorly because they're often
mismatched against people who were
accepted on their merits and that to me
is very sad then my question is like in
college we learned that it's only
because with the college degree that you
have a higher chance of getting a high
income you know people with a high
school degree don't earn as much as a
person with a associate degree and then
a bachelor's degree in Masters right
because of affirmative action without
affirmative action would there be any
other way for minorities your way what
you worked hard yes has nothing to do
with the color of your skin and by the
way that's also not you let me tell you
some of your studying political science
yes okay
I'm you're gonna get mad at me to tell
you this but you realize that if you
would have gone to a trade school for
nursing or working in an oil field or
electrician you would be making more
money doing that and studying Poli Sci
you would have made a lot more money
there you go even then you would make
far more money in a trade with your
apprenticeship and after only a couple
of years and after degree from UT so
again that would sort of reflect the
idea that going to an ivy Ivy League
school or a high-end school like
University of Austin is not an indicator
of economic success people right now who
go into trades do better than people who
go into universities and again a much
more important indicator is a nuclear
family a father and a mother in a
household far greater indicator than any
college degree and here's what's so
concerning to me you know you've heard
me talk about this before I've talked
about this with other people where I I
know that I'm getting repetitive but
it's because we're discussing the same
issue why do you think let me ask this
why do you think that black Americans in
the 1960s you know this is post Jim Crow
Voting Rights Act of 65 had really
strong family households like like your
family has talked about you know where
was less than 25 percent single
household rate why do you think from
1965 to 2019 we then ended up was a
nearly 80 percent single-parent
household rate what do you think
influence that of course there's a
cultural factor as conservatives knows
like culturally the black culture has
shifted from nuclear Ness to
but why with the conservative answer be
less Jesus no it's a good try I
appreciate if maybe that's a part of it
no a big big reason and it could be a
part of it actually sir I just thought
it was fighting with the conservative
say less Jesus you really have a fixed
view of what conservatives are no I
don't believe so no if you look at
actually in the 60s near Linden Johnson
the model Cities program and the modern
welfare program these were programs of
course aimed at righting the wrongs of
discrimination in the past specifically
targeted or aimed toward black people
and that incentivized single-parent
households so when trying to right the
wrongs of the past like slavery like Jim
Crow laws like voter suppression they
created new laws which I think we would
both agree were discriminatory and that
they were specifically targeting black
Americans which subsequently created
worst results I mean you look at the
model Cities program you look at schools
inner-city black areas where they have
much higher than average per pupil
spending but the graduation rate is
terrible then you look at them at black
people benefiting overwhelmingly from
from welfare programs but overwhelming
they're single-parent households because
there's an economic incentive with the
current welfare system to be a
single-parent household so in trying to
write the previous wrongs of systemic
discrimination they made them worse they
created more economic disparity and
doesn't that kind of mirror the idea of
affirmative action where it's well in
the past we didn't have enough black
students on campus so we need to write
that by excluding other people including
more blacks I think it mirrors the same
policies that have led to the
degradation of the black American family
and I think we see that in the results
of affirmative action primarily fewer
black Americans enrolling in top tier
higher education than even 35 years ago
it hasn't worked so solution is less
my solution is for them to be
performative based it really affirmative
action has been negligible in its
results the only results that we see I
would argue have been primarily negative
I would certainly argue maybe you could
argue this maybe you would disagree but
culturally it seems as though it's had
far more negative ramifications and
creating divisiveness on campus where
you know sometimes people feel like oh
that's an affirmative action student you
know or like you said you believe that
without affirmative action you wouldn't
be on this campus I think the effect has
been negative I think overall I'm being
fair the effect statistically has been
negligible and I would prefer to focus
on academic standards and certainly not
harm anyone because they're lacking a
specific skin color I think you worked
really hard from what you told me I
haven't seen your test scores but I
believe you I assume you've worked very
hard and you deserve to be here and you
should feel confident and believe that
you have a right to be here just as I
think that an Asian American who is here
should believe and understand that they
have the right to be here based on the
merits of their performance and the
contents of the character not because of
some diversity program yes
again I'm reiterating this question
because it means a lot so I appreciate
it um if we base it on just performing
for performance how how is their agent
students outperform even white people so
would you wouldn't that just make it
like a full bunch of Asians
no no no not necessarily they would
disproportionately makeup water student
body on campus in the New York New York
schools de Blasio had a huge pushback
against minority people because the top
schools were just filled with a
generational fence
no no white people Asians yo agents and
and a big reason for that is because you
know the Asian community at large is
placed a lot of importance on academics
and when I say performative by the way I
don't just mean SAT scores right because
I don't know if you're familiar with the
Harvard lawsuit but they were very it
was pretty racist against Asians because
they see what we measure a bunch of
different standards like yes right but a
lot of those are intangible a lot of
them are variables that can't be
quantified and so they would
disproportionately weigh Asian and
saying like Oh
seems very math focused not particularly
socially inclined when I say
performative standards I don't just mean
the test scores but extracurriculars you
know like you talked about or what other
programs you enrolled in whether their
activities what kind of contributions to
your community those are all
performative when I say performed I mean
including all of those just not for the
same reason that it's considered racism
maybe if I explain it this way you might
understand YouTube has this policy and
so do a lot of universities and when
people talk about hate speech which I
don't agree with but I don't agree that
hate speech is a thing but they base it
on the idea of if you insult or
denigrate someone based on what they
call intrinsic characteristics meaning
things that they have no control over
they can't change like race sex gender
that consider that hate speech in a lot
of these countries however that is the
exact same standard that affirmative
action uses in determining student
applicants I believe in quantifying all
of the variables that are performative
just not the same intrinsic
characteristics we don't believe people
should insult one for race sex or gender
sorry sexual orientation that should not
be included because I believe by
definition it's racist I just don't want
to like for students who have no other
way to like get in like if they didn't
have again a very extensive resin
or they didn't have a lot of
opportunities to do a lot of service
service you did you're from what from
what you've said not insulting you're
from a very small town with not a lot to
offer yes and sounds to me like you did
a whole lot as much as I could with the
resources that would give it right I
mean I'm like why shouldn't we expect
that from everyone else
well people wasn't a lot on paper what
you contributed was a lot so in others
are you saying that you don't think you
deserve a spot at UT are you saying that
you think you got in because you're
black yeah you do hmm maybe the fact
that you don't know right now do you see
that isn't that a bad thing that's not a
good thing I want you to be able to say
I deserve to be here and you know what
wouldn't it be better let's say there
wasn't a whole lot on paper okay let's
say that's the case I don't know I
assume that you probably did pretty well
but let's say there's not a whole lot on
paper wouldn't it still be better for
you to go to a community college right
get those credits and know that you
deserve your spot at UT so that when I
ask you this question right now beyond
any shadow of a doubt you can say no I
earned my spot here I was more qualified
than anyone else that's when I that's
why I'm at UT don't you think you'd feel
better and giving that answer I would
it's just that right now I don't see
anything other than formative action
right now that would I rather live with
a doubt and still get the opportunities
you know like cuz if I if there's doubt
that I got here I can now that I'm here
I could I can push myself even forward
to really earn it you know should have
burned it before you got here and I
think you probably did yeah
and that's here's the thing when you
look at the statistics they can't no
black students can't know right if you
are admitted because of formative action
exists okay even if you are more
qualified than that Asian student if I
asked that student this question right
now they have to answer the same way
that you do I don't know I think I
deserve to be here but I don't know it
was affirmative action but they have to
answer that same way as the student who
is an affirmative action acceptance
right that's sad
even the person who is undoubtedly
qualified who deserved
spot they can never answer yes I deserve
to be here and be proud of their
accomplishments that being said Asians
on campus can answer it and white
students on campus can answer it because
they had to perform to higher standards
so if I ask the same question right now
to an Asian student on campus did you
earn your spot here do you deserve to be
here they will be able to tell me beyond
any shadow of a doubt absolutely
I earned higher in the SATs I did more
extracurriculars I earned my spot at
this university you can't because of the
policy in place and that to me is a very
young it's not only beyond the idea that
affirmative action hasn't been effective
I think that's immoral because it
destroys the human spirit in doubting
yourself I just wouldn't want to take
away any any hope other than later
what's the plan other than this I'm
picking up a perm of action what can I
give minority students that can still
give them the hope and a chance to get
it I think you need to give them
anything I don't think you need to give
them anything I think the more you give
them when you say that and by the way
we're talking about policies it's
usually rich white liberals saying the
more we can give black people and then
it destroys the black American family
right the more we can give black
students and then you have to answer
what self doubt that you don't know if
you've warranted a spot here doesn't
seem in giving people anything has
worked out very well I think that we
should stop looking at students with the
prism of lens and try and look at
accomplishments character and
intellectual diversity who was who said
not judged by the color of his skin but
the content of his character Martin
Luther King I believe that we should
apply that same standard on University
let me ask you this final question ok ok
I've really enjoyed our conversation I
hope I hope this has been productive too
as well for you let's say that your
application so you were saying you
didn't really have a whole lot but you
had a great essay let's say UT said to
you we like what we see but you don't
have experience in necessarily the right
programs we would like to see you
reapply next year after accruing some
credits at a community college right if
they said that to you what would you
have done
I would have gotten those credits and
done great with them I mean I would have
110% on those grades on those credits I
mean everyone can do that what made you
get into UT wasn't your race it was what
you just described to me which was your
work ethic and how you view the world
and my point is let's say even if you
were an affirmative action applicant I
don't know that you were I'm not hearing
the kind of attitude from someone who
was I think you probably earned your
spot here but you're telling me that if
they said try again you would have tried
again until you got you had gotten it
then know that you've earned your spot
here and make the most of it and
understand that everyone else should be
held to that same standard that you hold
yourself to that's what I'm saying
see we agree thank you so much Tina for
sitting down I appreciate it Thank You
Tina correct yeah thank you hold on
don't move let me make sure you got a
spider okay it's gone thank you so much
I really appreciate you taking the time
and beans and thank you for telling me
your story
absolutely god bless thank you Stallman
have changed my mind click one of these
other installments in the videos playing
in boxes here that's the only way you'll
find them because if you search change
my mind they might not show up because
YouTube's deemed them controversial
subscribe hit the notification bell and
you know we'll we'll see you but we
probably won't